The teacher of Vivek and Camilla gave them a system
of linear equations to solve.
They did it with the help of a few steps they led
to the systems shown in the table below.
We have the original system of the teacher,
what has Vivek received after having done several actions,
what she has received after she has done several actions.
Which one has received a system that is equivalent
of the system of teacher's equations?
The first question we should ask,
is what does it mean to have an equivalent system?
For the purpose of this task or for our purposes,
equivalent to a system is a system that has the same solution as the one given.
If there is a pair (x, y) that satisfies
the system of teacher's equations, which is the solution
the teacher 's system and
the system of equations of Vivek, then we will call it equivalent,
because it has the same solution.
This also applies to Camilla's system, if there is the same solution,
we will call it equivalent to the teacher's system.
Let's make some comparisons here.
First let's take a look at Vivek's.
The first equation is unchanged
equation of the teacher,
it is no different than that of the teacher,
means any solution that satisfies both equations,
will certainly be the solution of the above equation,
because it is literally the same as the above equation
the teacher. So it happens.
Let's take a look at the second.
The second equation here is definitely different.
We can verify that it has not only been multiplied
by any number on both sides.
To make it a zero, if we multiply,
we will multiply 1 by 0
and then, in order to maintain equality,
we will do this on the other side.
But 0 on this left side will be 0,
we will get 0 equals 0,
so he not only divided the two sides of a number,
but seems to have done another action.
It looks like he probably added or pulled out
something on both sides. Let's see how
has received this here.
It started from -4h
plus 5u is equal to 1.
And it seems he has been able to get it
-3x plus 7th
is equal to 0.
Let's see what it was supposed to do to get this.
It is sure...
To go from -4x to -3x,
must have added x,
so I will just write there x.
To go from 5th to 7th,
must have added 2u.
So on the left he added
x plus 2u.
Note that there we have x plus 2.
And on the right side
took 1 or added minus 1.
Here we see -1.
He has collected the left sides
of these two equations to get this new left side,
and has gathered the right sides,
to get this new right hand.
And this is a perfectly acceptable action.
This new equation we received,
this new linear equation will present
different rights than here,
but the resulting system will have the same solution.
Why we are confident that the resulting system
will there be the same solution?
For a pair (x, y) that satisfies both equations,
this will be the decision:
for this pair (x, y), x plus 2u
is equal to minus 1.
About this solution
we add the same thing to both sides.
We say, "I will add x plus 2
to the left side.
And if I do not want to change equality,
I have to add the same thing to the right side. "
We have been told about the solution of this equation, that
x plus 2u is equal to minus 1,
so minus 1 is the same as x plus 2u
for that decision, and so we will not change
the resulting system solution.
What Vivek has done is a perfectly acceptable action -
has gathered the left sides
and then gathered the right sides,
to get this new second equation.
This will not change the system's decision.
In fact, this method is often used
to find the solution of a system of equations.
Now let's take a look at Camilla's.
Its first equation is the same
as the second equation of the teacher.
Let's see her second equation
how it relates to the first equation.
Appraised by an eye,
it looks like it
has multiplied both sides by some number.
And it seems that this number is ... That she has multiplied
the right side by minus 8.
So below minus 8.
Minus 1 minus 8 is plus 8.
And it seems she has multiplied
and the left side by minus 8.
Minus 8 by x is minus 8x.
Minus 8 in 2u is minus 16u.
It has simply multiplied both sides of the same value,
which in fact does not change the equation.
This will be...
It changes the appearance,
but in reality presents the same rights.
This is definitely an equivalent system.
These are still the same conditions.
We will have the same solution.
When dealing with equation systems,
you will not change the system's decision,
if you multiply both sides of an equation by
any number or if you collect and subtract the equations.
When I say collection and subtraction of the equations,
I mean, you add the left side to the left side
and the right side to the right,
here it is - you pull it out of the other
on the left, and if we remove the lower one
from the upper left side
and remove the lower one from the top right,
this will not change the decision.
Both have received a system of equations equivalent to that of the teacher,
that is, the same solution
such as that of the teacher.